foreign
[Music]
good morning good evening wherever the
Hell in the world you are and welcome to
Sidetrack you have Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel which I never get bored of
saying that's weird
green screen speed map green screens
appeared anyway
the mat is joint Matt is joining us
today that one I don't know God damn it
mirroring affects me I'd never be a
fighter pilot that way
um
Matt's joined us today and stormy that
down is easier stormy's joined us from
Over the cross the pond and you're in
the basement terrorists
is here this is wow the people in the
comments hello Shelly hello Georgie
never called him Georgie before but hey
we'll see that because surprise how the
hell are you what are you up to
oh yeah
I'm doing all right but I have like I
was saying too there you go I have just
found out I've got covered so
yeah
so guys we'll do what we always do
because we haven't really got a top
picker this week so instead we will just
talk about whatever how we want to talk
about
um what have you been watching this week
let's start there
um stormy oh look at that
look what I got in the mail
oh that looks really good I'm really
happy with that that's that good thank
you for that I really do appreciate it
well it was my little thank you to you I
was gonna put the Sidetrack on it and I
thought no you know what I won't
advertise myself for once
I stole it once
uh yeah no I'm doing a pretty good I'm
coughing less
um good covered negative now yeah he
said the c word again God damn it
I had the
I I had the corona group
a few years ago on YouTube that would
have got us kicked off quicker than what
you said a couple of weeks
so what you've been watching and stormy
how you been what you've been doing
um
I watched the first three
three loads of Andor and I was mightily
impressed yeah no negatives at all
the only negative was episode four
hasn't come out
I mean it was
uh the cast was excellent the writing I
mean I was really engaged I mean it was
it was a more of a personal story as
opposed to some you know technology
story
you know you really feel for
um Cassian and his plight and how he got
to be where he is and who he is
and
um I don't want to give too much away
but it was just uh they will be spoilers
because we're talking about what we've
watched this week so we'll be spoilers
right
to be honest to talk to you guys the
Star Wars fans about this because
obviously you know I'm not as massive a
Star Wars fan as you guys so I just
wondered if there were like little
background things I would have missed
not many not many I like a few of the
characters keep coming and going I'm
like am I supposed to know who that is
and um I know Cassian is obviously from
from the movie but
um the only person maybe
that you should as far as episodes one
two three I think
I mean there's no Vader there's no Luke
Skywalker nothing like that
but we'll get to Mon mothma and some uh
oh my God Jimmy Smith's character uh uh
uh Senator Morgana as well soon so yeah
the other thing I was watching is when I
got covered I said well I'm just going
to watch all the episodes of Stargate
everything and I finally finished that
this last week finally finished I went
through Stargate sg1 and Atlantis and
Universal wrapped up Universe two nights
ago and
I'll notice something
about the intro to Stargate Atlantis
that I have to address
Robert picardo got rocked
now this is a small tiny nuanced thing
that probably only I would notice
but if you remember the uh the uh titles
to Atlantis you know um especially the
late seasons
they have a picture of the actor and
then it freezes and then there's kind of
a watery wipe yeah it goes across her
face
every actor gets that except Robert for
cardo his character just gets to freeze
but it doesn't get the fancy water
effect and I think MGM needs to fix that
I really do it just bugs the crap out of
it
um
because yes really likes me we got on
really really well
yeah that's the one crazy thing I
noticed about all that is like okay
there's a trend here Jay with people who
created Stargate not liking you
France loves me I'll have you know I've
spoken to Brad a few times since the
mistake yeah Robert C Cooper as well
but Joseph malozi annoyed me first so
um is it we had we had an interesting
discussion about climate change
through a massive argument
uh I also you know kept up with the um
latest and greatest of um rings of power
and House of the Dragon that's what and
that kind of all right that's it for me
well guys have a quick link because then
we've got a list of a couple of things
we're going to talk about there we've
got to talk about andal we've got to
talk about uh dragons and her
um but Lord rings of power
that is kicked up a gear but Paris what
what have you been keep pointing the
wrong freaking way Harris what were you
going I'm not used to being in this
corner I'm normally over here
that's because there's four of us this
week Harris what you've been watching me
well I've been busy rings of power and
or House of the dragon all that good
stuff
um of course Rick and Morty keeping up
with Rick and Morty and uh they had
I know you're not keeping up with it Jay
but they had the creepiest not the
creepiest I guess one of the only
episodes that I've ever felt icky
watching Rick and Morty with last
episode
and that's odd for Rick and Morty you
know but uh anyway uh
movie-wise I've seen Barbarian Pearl See
How They Run
the woman King and then I just saw
Avatar re-released and don't worry
darling uh uh good Lord so I've I've
been in the movie theater you have a job
at the moment I'm an actor depends on
the day I don't know so you don't have a
job at the moment okay that explains so
you're researching doing all this stuff
man that is that that's work yeah
I'm doing it you're trying to tell my
wife can you take your customer tickets
back on your tax expenses
I need to
in my living room there are so many in
this country there's literally Costa on
every like I if I walk out my front door
with my eyes closed I will 100 trip over
Acosta they're just they're just
everywhere but are they in America
they're in petrol stations as well now
yeah they're in the petrol station I was
at
I like the coffee shop that's owned by
that um NHL guy they're just a donut
they do really nice Donuts uh Tim Tim
something anyway Canadian guy
uh I feel like I know what you're
talking about I don't know I'm not a
coffee drinker
it's Tim Hortons there you go
timing and I'm freaking it's really
freaking good Donuts
I'm just absolutely tiny I'm only that
big
um come on Matty what you've been
watching before we get stuck into all
these TV shows I really want to talk
about handle
watching that much this this week to be
honest I watched Quantum Leap uh watch
the first episode of that animated video
because
I I hadn't seen The Originals because
I'm young
so it was like it was out before I was
born so he looks like he's in his 40s
but he's actually only 22 years old yeah
I did make a joke about that in the
video so and look out for that
um
I watched the first episode of rings of
power and that was pretty good I quite
enjoyed that
I'm not really a Lord of the Rings fan
hmm like I've never I've watched the
movies and then I never went back to
them like I'm not I'm not a die-hard fan
or anything like that but I watched it
and it's pretty good
um other than that what have I watched
uh
I've watched Big Bang Theory and that's
pretty much it yeah
it's almost a Sci-Fi they talk about
sci-fi lighting it
um the only other thing that guys I've
watched that you didn't get mentioned
there was
um the newest low decks
but I thought it was just as brilliant
as all of the other low decks and I was
I've been off this week so I've actually
watched a fair bit of just nonsense and
done loads of those videos you're
welcome uh but um it's it's you know
it's just like
I just love low decks I think it's just
the best show I'm telling you at the
moment I just I absolutely love loading
it's the best Star Trek it's it's there
with strange new worlds for me I'm just
like I don't know I really really enjoy
it
um but anyway I wanted to talk about and
or
first of all something I mentioned in my
video that I did on Tuesday about angles
I absolutely love that streaming
services can now like put three episodes
out like that because I mean those three
episodes really like tied a lovely bow
on the like it's it's yeah if you know
it's like it's such a lovely little Trio
of episodes and I found the first two
episodes a bit boring I will be honest I
thought they were good but by the end of
the third episode you're just like oh
yeah bring it on
what do you guys think well first of all
what do you guys think about like the
streaming services and
um because most people hate streaming
services they keep they from the killing
the genre stuff but I think things like
this drop in three episodes and stuff
like that I think that's a big problem I
I I used to have cable you know you know
I think last time I had cable was like
200 channels
and I watched five of them you know a
third or even maybe more than that were
sports related I mean I really don't
need 20 channels of hockey you know uh
or all the preaching channels that's on
here in America
and I I was like AMC Sci-fi channel HBO
and The Weather Channel you know the
things that I watched
but now you know I've got maybe
um four or five streaming services I pay
for
and I get more sci-fi more fantasy
and and with and they're all better
quality Productions
and no and no wrestling
you know none of the like sci-fi's just
started running you know years ago
started running uh wrestling on one
night
what I want I never did understand that
programming switch
so I I think I'm getting
I'm also paying one-third the price of
what I was paying with cable for all the
stuff I didn't want to watch so I think
I'm getting a better deal
plus I'm getting better content I'm
tickled with streaming services and you
can watch it whenever you want yeah
which is yeah bonus you know you don't
have to have a terabyte hard drive
recording all the crap you're not going
to watch yeah yeah
even a thing these days
I don't know my sky box maybe apparently
holds about a terabyte but then every
time I try to watch something it it
makes me download I'm like no you say
you've got a terabyte just remember it's
for God's sake
it's not that much nowadays though no
but I'm halfway through Stargate series
four so that'll be our next review
episode I'm gonna have to remember I've
just watched
just watched my favorite episode of all
time
probably my favorite episode just to sit
and watch it's not the it's not the best
episode by any stretch's imagination but
to sit I can watch that over and over
and over again now absolutely anyway
how's what do you think of a stream this
is just out of interesting
or whatever they they better worse and
back and forth with them I I I love them
for certain things and I dislike them
for certain things I guess so most the
time the thing that I dislike about him
is dropping a bunch of episodes at once
sometimes it's necessary with things
like and or words like literally in act
one two three for the first three
episodes and you need you need that
almost together which does kind of worry
me a little bit about if they're doing
four different separate one two three
acts within these little uh many
narratives with Andor that we're only
going to get the First Act again this
week which might kind of sour people I
doubt it I hope not but that's like my
only worry I guess going into that but
uh typically I'm I'm old-fashioned and
like
I want that week to digest what I just
watched and I want to think about it I
want to be I want it to be good enough
to force me to think about it for a week
instead of all right on to the next one
yeah sometimes a show is not meant for
that though and it's it's just an easier
way to have a streamer so I I really
just think it depends on the medium
itself or on the on the project itself
but typically I'm a week by week kind of
guy well streaming services I've tried
to start to do that some shows it does
seem to be but I'm assuming in the
monological by the the guy that's doing
the new Battlestar Galactica TV show
whether it's a reboot or a continuation
very quick use an article but anyway
um he was talking about this new saying
the thing he loves about streaming
services is halfway through the series
they're planning there's this big battle
um but it's a three-way battle
so they've been saying is we're going to
dump all three episodes that one week
and this is like two-thirds away through
the series sort of thing because then
you're gonna see the same thing from
three different perspectives dumped all
in one hit sort of thing because it
works for the story and you can't do
that on cable you've just got the week
week yeah you kind of miss the looking
forward to the next episode you know
that makes sense a little bit kind of
like Andor though just if you have that
I mean everything comes in threes
especially with film and that's just
kind of
it's easy it's still easy to digest in
that way I guess because it's three
different angles of the same thing I I
don't know I like that idea
yeah exactly no I yeah I do like that
but so I I'm 100 with you though the
only thing I really
don't like about streaming services we
never get that 22 episode series anymore
ever they can only ever do 10 episodes
and I don't I don't know why because
they could
um I know the budgets are different but
why not do
I mean Disney kind of do with like
Booker Bob effect I don't think but
they're doing like three seasons a year
but so you're still getting like 30
episodes but I missed I missed those 22
Episodes but anyway um keep pointing
that way Matty
what do you think about streaming
services but
I like them
I prefer I prefer
I prefer having a a series drop all at
once
although when I grew up everything that
was on TV was
see it next week the week after week
after week after I have always been
very impatient very very impatient back
when I was in secondary school high
school whatever you want to call it
we I was watching Heroes so if any of
you watched that yeah it was on Sky uh
Sky one I think in the UK
and it come out every single week
it wasn't it was on BBC One but anyway
Carol was it on BBT
or was it Stargate that's on Sky one
Star Games
anyway we'll have this argument later
but anyway that damn water bottle kills
me every damn time it's just huge Paris
is also tiny he's only little
my water bottle makes up half of me
what is water bottle looks like compared
to me yeah that's massive
yeah when I was in school I was watching
Heroes I was always the the person who
would download it from America because
they were always like six weeks ahead
yeah just so I could watch it
because I don't like waiting and that's
what I like to start streaming I like it
when they drop a few episodes at the
very beginning
but really what I tend to do is I'll
wait until they're all out and then I'll
binge them all in one go
or over a course for a couple of days I
might I might not watch an entire season
in one in one day because sometimes they
are pretty long like stranger things for
example some of those episodes were like
nearly two hours long so that was not
gonna happen in a day
but then like a series like um Cobra Kai
comes out and I slashed through in like
three days and I'm now I'm like no of
course there's more than I
um and I really loved it I didn't really
enjoy the last season I thought I got a
bit boring but this season I'm just like
yeah kick his ass Daniel
um I really really enjoyed it
um but yeah I kind of missed the I kind
of missed the weekly look at you know
sitting down waiting for it you know the
um the excitement of that oh it's on
it's on come on so I I I manufacture
that excitement now when it's like the
last episode we'll get some popcorn and
a bit of drink and we'll sit down and
we'll you know it's like as a family or
whatever and watch it you know so I try
to manufacture the that excitement
instead but I think I do think it loses
something when they just dump it all in
one week
yeah I feel like there's so much content
out there to watch nowadays I'm never
caught up
like those TV shows that I haven't even
started yet so the very the fact that I
can just binge a season
and kind of like just enjoy it and then
it's done and I can wait for the up I
can wait a year for it to do to for the
next one to come out
I can start something else there's
always something that I can always
something oh my God
and there's you never have to wait long
for something new anyways I cannot do it
like back in the day when it was
thinking like there was a lot of TV on
in the summer months because I'm sorry
in the winter months because everyone's
at home so viewing figures went through
the roof so that's when all like the big
shows are on and in the summer months
there wasn't so much you know the summer
seasons it was a bit you know like
sometimes you'd be scrapping around for
something to watch I haven't had that
problem for years no just they just
don't do it that way in the morning so
but yeah four to six huge shows on right
now there's it's amazing
House of the Dragon because I never
ended up finishing Game of Thrones
Game of Thrones
well I really want to watch House of
dragons and I love Matt Smith so yeah
it's damn good so far with Game of
Thrones to do just what you should
always do with Game of Thrones you just
not watched last episode of the series
just every single fact the the last but
one episode is always the brilliant
episode and then they have one episode
with an exotic like yeah let's sort of
like set [ __ ] up for next week uh next
season and I'm saying I don't bother so
just just skip that one just watch the
one before because it's freaking amazing
and then you don't have the
disappointment the rest of us had with
like I've been watching this for eight
[ __ ] years and that's how they ended
thanks but yeah no I'm loving actually
Dragon I think it's great I think Matt
Smith is really you know in the next
episode though everyone's going to jump
like 10 years in the future I am worried
about that just a little bit I like them
you know I liked the the queen I think
she's great I think yeah so the um the
the one that's gonna be Queen
she looks 12 years old that was my
problem and I didn't like the sex scenes
after mid all the way through I'm going
no she looks like a child I don't like
this I think a good creep me out she's
like almost a year year and a half
younger than me yeah
I was shocked
yeah I Googled it because it was
creeping me out where Matt Smith was
touching her up and I was just like oh I
don't like this oh creepy
um but yeah so get ready for that all no
actors next week Happy Days Happy Days
that's that's the night
because it's not
um 6 p.m our time that's what eight
hours from now seven and a half hours
we get it Mondays oh damn it no that's
that pisses me off we're always just
that little behind you guys like my
Prime actually ages to at least it's not
at least it's not six weeks behind like
it used to be yeah yeah I'll get that
I'll get that sorry only 12 hours but
anyway
that is I mean I think somebody in the
comments mentioned it a little while ago
um but it is Star Wars for properly
grown-ups I mean Star Wars is always for
grown-ups but that's seriously I mean I
think I commented in my video that um
there's definitely a pace to it and I do
wish it would speed it up a little bit
but yes that Star Wars so Star Wars has
always been a bit slow paced I think for
me anyway
um you know but then when the action
starts it really kicks off but that
third episode I thought was brilliant
what do you guys think of the general
feeling of the series compared to sort
of like other the other stuff we're
getting does it is it comparable stormy
do you think I I think so the thing that
struck me the most and this is something
I never really thought about
was you know here you have the empire
and with
um
all of their technology all their
prowess all of their manufacturing
capability you never really do see the
ass side of that I mean they were to see
the the other side of that you know with
all uh in terms of waste and disposable
culture and disposable technology you
know we really I mean yeah we see
tattooing and oh my God I'm grateful
that so far there's been no Tattooing in
a Star Wars story with no tattooing I'm
good with that I said that that's pretty
much the first thing I said in the video
it's not
Untouchables
though right
huh y'all notice they just replaced
tattooing with another pharynx is just
another desert Planet it just has a
couple more uh houses on damn it
you know
uh you know it's like the children and
I'm guessing uh from qunari that were
abandoned or orphaned or something you
know you never see I mean we see the
grittiest it's been is probably we've
seen so far has been Mandalorian in
terms of how it is and Mandalorian was
one step grittier than
um the in Tatooine
um and we never really see that we're
seeing a little bit more I think of the
corporate
culture or the the corporatization of of
government in in Andor and these are
fresh things I haven't seen really
before
yeah the constabulary was an interesting
little trust I I commented on that as
well like we're seeing like a little bit
more detail on how the empire
particularly early on actually like got
its got control and took over control
and it seems to have done it through
money it was basically we invaded India
that's basically what the British we
didn't actually go in with an army we're
just sort of like went in with some
money and went would you like to be
British and they're like yeah that'd be
lovely thank you yeah um
just sort of went that's great I'm gonna
call my children Peter from now on I'm
like great brilliant and I'm sorry yeah
we called we we're just out organized
the
[Music]
um
but what about you Harrison I'm thinking
like saying
this this series does to me feel like it
fits in with the movie it's it's the
style and everything is very much
supposed to blend into the film but does
it fit with the rest of Star Wars
that is a good question because it's it
it almost feels sometimes everything
yeah yeah I mean you know it's it's
almost I've heard a lot of people say
it's almost blade runnery in Star Wars
and it it does almost feel like a
different version of sci-fi tossed into
the Star Wars uh universe
but I don't think it detracts from that
at all I think it still has a good
foothold there while expanding upon
things
um it really does feel like Rogue one
which makes me really happy because
and I mean it depends on the day whether
I'm an Empire Strikes Back a Return of
the Jedi which which one I'm like more
of a fan of because I mean Return of the
Jedi is not as good of a film but I got
I'm a soft spot at for it you know I
love it but Rogue one is I'm not the
biggest fan of all the Disney stuff
necessarily I love all their animation
and stuff but Rogue one is a lot of the
time maybe one of my favorite if not my
favorite Star Wars film so this is it is
excellent It's just so well made on
every single level I I love it uh I I
can't believe the crew got
split up and the whole production Fiasco
a little bit happened at the tail end
there because they still managed yeah
you know but uh I'm glad they got Gilroy
back for it because you can you can feel
him in the essence of the series so far
and it's more serious because of it and
I don't know I I at the moment I like it
because it is adding a level to Star
Wars because you can still feel that
foothold there so it's still still Star
Wars but
it's one of the first times I feel like
the the Galaxy's expanding without like
truly just World building and and you
get that character development wow
the Blade Runner link blew my mind
actually because I think about
particularly in the first episode when
he's walking down all those raining
streets and I think I think they get
that was like that's Blade Runner yeah
what do you guys think about
and Matt
why can Disney do a good Star Wars TV
series but they can't seem to do a good
Star Wars movie other than Rogue one
time
okay
they have a lot of time
um series to flesh out a story but they
don't have a lot of time to flesh up
flesh out the plot on a movie
so they tried to rush things this first
trilogy
yeah because George Lucas is infinitely
better than anyone at Disney
that's just that's just how that's like
that's how I think of it they
I think they can they can do really good
stories like Disney has always been good
at storytelling but
when it comes to Star Wars I just don't
think they know how to do it on with the
movies they know how to do it with TV
because they've got like 10 episodes to
like flesh flesh it out and make us
invested in the characters and actually
want to
watch the next season that comes out but
with the movies
they just rushing so so much that we
often feel like
that was crap I don't want to watch the
next movie or they do something
that it just doesn't make any sense I
think you can make take more risks with
the TV series as well because you've got
10 episodes and if you do something
that's a bit like with
[Music]
um
oh okay what was the the middle of the
last trilogy
The Last Jedi well they almost made it
like a comedy there's like there's quite
a lot of humor in it and I still cannot
get over the whole
bit I generally just wanted to stand up
and just throw things at the TV a lot of
money so I didn't
um but it's just like oh that was [ __ ]
um but I actually quite like the new
Trilogy I I loved them I thought they
were great they're much better than the
um clone wars and although that trilogy
um but obviously they're not compared to
the originals so because nothing yeah I
feel like with with the Last Jedi a lot
of the things that people didn't like
like the fact
they basically change the force
for the sake of the plot
um if that was on a TV series and they
had a lot more time to flesh it out and
actually have some sort of explanation
as to why that's happened because Luke's
been on that island now for like what 30
years or
we've lost map
oh
no he's Frozen
well while we get when we get mad back
there's one thing I watched that I just
did not like
I'm a couple weeks ago we were talking
about if we had like a billion dollar
budget what all would we fund and one of
the things was I asked about was uh Tom
Swift which was the children a set of
children's books back oh man starting
the 30s I think is based on you know a
kid along with a Hardy Boys kind of
theme but he was a scientist his dad was
a big scientist and hey I would love to
see a Tom Swift show now that was what I
was going to spend some of my budget on
Well turns out I think like one of you
guys mentioned there was one on the CW
so I went to go watch episode one and I
should have been shot in the head
instead
it was
I was not prepared to see a gay hip-hop
version of Tom Swift
I mean he lived in rapper mansion He had
rapper cars he you know
uh he had rapper sneakers and all of
that
really detracted from oh his dad got
killed you know and so there was
supposed to be in this relationship you
know if in the original books Tom Swift
had a really good relationship with his
dad
well here it starts off with
him and his dad can't stand each other
or they may there's all this Rift
between him and then Dad goes off to
Jupiter and he dies
and so uh
it was
yeah it sounds awful yeah so if you get
the chance try 30 minutes of it and it
was on the CW which
yeah there's a lot of things on CW that
go on for seasons and this got canceled
within just a few months
oh look it's Matt he's back
how much did you
do I can't remember I stopped listening
off my three to be honest man I was
looking at the wall I was just talking
then all of a sudden all these swirly
things started happening and I'm like oh
God
anyway
what was I even saying uh something
about handle I don't know we talked
about
um
I'll talk about the Last Jedi and the
fact that they basically changed the
force yeah they've done that in a TV
series and had say 10 episodes to flesh
out why they've changed the force Luke
has been on this island now for 30 odd
years he's studying the force with all
these Scrolls and all that crap like
that could have been explained way
better rather than oh the force is now
changed and he can now project himself a
million miles
like it could have been way better and I
don't think people would have been
pissed off if if it was in the TV series
this
the serious question our streaming
series the one they're done properly
like this are they better than movies
yeah
well I mean for my for my opinion is
okay so I've got a warped opinion about
movies
you know that I go to the theater if I a
lot of people go to the movies and they
only want to see you know if it's more
than 90 minutes oh it was a long movie
see I want to pay my 10 bucks or
whatever and go see a three hour movie
because I'm getting more minutes per
dollar so if right right so you know if
I get like 10 hours of a story
that's thumbs up but if it's you know
and this is just me and my you know
thinking of the economics of time and I
don't know it's just the uh Series so
that did you watch Kenobi
yes so you know that that was originally
written as a film and it was supposed to
be three films and to expand it they
turned it into a TV show and they
watered like Capital watered that down
huh I feel like
lucasfilm does better with films unless
it's animation animation with lucasfilm
I think they're they're they're they're
they're I don't know their thought
process is different and they do that in
a whole different way I mean like bad
batch was wonderful I thought
it it was slow in a couple episodes but
it's the first season and the the whole
Camino Arc was yeah
yes I mean in the cold Camino Arc was so
important to like tons
yeah yeah it's it's it's a pivotal part
of Star Wars now and and that I will to
segue back in the Andor a little bit
that I think is one of the most
interesting parts of
of Andor so far it did
of course there's little
pocket Rebels going on probably yeah the
Empire and all that kind of stuff but
did the true obviously cassian's gonna
be
brought into I guess a larger Rebel
organization but a good chunk of the
Rebellion started because of two guys
that got shot on a brothel in the middle
of a street
it doesn't sound too bad I like it a
little bit it adds that little that
almost like childlike Wonder while still
keeping it a little more adult-like in
Star yeah shot in front of a brothel kid
like
wondering it's all started from two dead
guys but no exactly
breast and brothel brothel and then the
same guy said [ __ ] a couple minutes
later
first real customer
it's all right I I love the um I guess I
love the realism I love the like sort of
the the police even though that Chief
Constable or whatever he is he's a
Wheezy little turd of a human being
I can't stand that guy we I know you're
not supposed to like but that's the
point but cowed a little twerp
um but I I love the I love how real it
feels I love how it's gritty I think I
commented in my video this is exactly
take the aliens out of this this is like
one of those really good like Nordic
murder mystery shows that everyone gets
mad excited about and then the BBC or
somebody will remake it a couple years
later and make it not as good it's
another Scandinavian you know like drums
you take the aliens out and it's it's a
pretty good you know it's a good drama
the pace nothing's similar as well yeah
um but obviously then there's somebody
will fly past and a floating motorbike
you speeds to whatever
um
I thought andal was really good I
actually really really enjoyed it um
more than I thought I would but I have
to admit by the end of the second
episode I was like something needs to
happen soon
um but it then it did so Happy Days
um I I
said that I just mate actually years ago
who said um yeah this theory about Star
Wars and he said that he wasn't sure the
Rebellion were actually the good guys
I was like what you mean you know what
the um the Empire is really well funded
really well supported and really well
organized and then like out of a
population of hundreds of billions
there's like 50 people that turn up and
like have a rebellion
surely if they were the good guys
wouldn't they be better supported than
that and I was like
yeah [ __ ] maybe they're the bad guys it
sounds they all seem to be criminals
they're all bloody like um you know drug
dealers and things like Rebellion yeah
it's essentially a terrorist cell isn't
it really yeah
[Laughter]
legally yeah
that's me I'm not so sure the uh and
Hansel was 100 a drug dealer
same thing weren't the separatists kind
of the good guys and the prequels not
really the uh
not the Republic was just screwing
everybody over the entire time
different type of government screwing
but I mean then I mean the Empire then
did build like death stars I don't think
the Republic ever did did that they just
taxed everyone to death there's the
difference between taxing to death and
building a really big gun that can shoot
the tax star it just comes down and
extracts all of your wealth honestly at
that point just [ __ ] shoot me oh
excuse me just shoot me at that point
isn't the reason that the Death Star was
built originally
like before Disney decolonized
everything because there was like some
Invasion gonna happen
maybe like after the events of
um returning the Jedi so before Disney
got their hands on it the original story
had some sort of invasion and the
emperor the emperor was essentially
leading up to that it was showing that
he had really good foresight that he was
like was this the enemy from outside of
the Galaxy yeah I don't know much about
it because I've not read that books
hasn't read little bits but yeah it was
it was clearly under development before
Palpatine became emperor you know
you know because you know the plans are
already finished you know when we first
see everybody on geonosa yeah
and one thing now larger has got it
unless they're using AI engineering
something that large is takes some time
to build
yeah but they didn't engineer it very
well though didn't they it was bad Ai
and exhaust ports torpedo-sized exhaust
pubs it just seems like a bad idea
um I still love that video I watch every
song the space now the space Wizards you
know that the guy that's um he's there
he's the engineer and he's in front of
the people
why didn't nobody tell me about space
was this what I was designing a damn
thing and it's a war sport that means
stuff is going out how did the torpedo
get sucked in oh yeah that's right space
Wizards
um
this week so we've got and off we
enjoyed that
answer the dragon still about that very
briefly because like I said we said it's
going to jump 10 years ahead
other than Matt Smith though in that
series is there anybody that's even
remotely likeable or memorable
oh Millie Alcock as renera has been he
said [ __ ]
but yeah no she's she's been excellent
in that show honestly uh I I do worry a
little bit going into the new episode
with all the
changes yeah all the I I do like Emma
Darcy I think it's her name and it's
going to be replacing her
I've seen her in one thing on Amazon
Prime truth Seekers which is that Nick
Frost funny uh right I love that I've
seen half of it I need to finish it but
it's not right
she's she's yeah she's that girl she's
the main girl in there uh
so I mean they're casting Department's
amazing so it's got to be good
yeah I really want to miss Millie Alcock
I gotta admit
um
everyone's saying [ __ ]
so so it makes me laugh
um [ __ ]
my mother's maiden name was Alcock
it's not that always makes me laugh all
that might be related to it so you need
a cameo that's what I was about to say
you know yeah it's cool I don't know
what did you think the way they've done
it like that though with this like the
first five episodes with like these
complete and then they just they've
jumped gears already in this series why
are they doing it well technically in
the where the book starts we're already
like a hundred years past where the book
starts they could have started this a
hundred years prior uh they've they've
just kind of picked us it's it's almost
like fire it's not truly comparable but
like Fire and Blood is similar to
uh Jr tolkien's
similar alien anyway in a way not in a
lot of ways but in certain ways where
it's more of a few words you were going
to set stormy off then for a second I
know
[Music]
bullet points of history and that's
about it
[Laughter]
he agrees
um but you know I think that's what do
you think Matt you've only watched the
first episode didn't you did you see
House of dragon I've not seen anything
at all I watched the first episode of
rings of power you can get power which
we'll talk about that in a minute
because I'd love the last episode
but um
I I still think it's better than I'm
still enjoying uh House of dragon more
than I'm enjoying ring a path
okay
last episode might be a little bit of a
Tipping Point for me though
um would you say
you can jump into house for Dragon
without having seen like the let's say
the last four seasons of Game of Thrones
oh yeah it happened hundreds of years
prior yeah it's a prequel so yeah I'll
I'll start watching it
yeah it is excellent
okay then so ring of power right so you
know that that obviously we we yelled a
lot at people that had decided they
hated this series before it started that
did my head in
um you know we won't talk about work
because I got in trouble last time I
didn't talk about work so um
but that was the argument
and the first couple of C episodes were
a bit dull
I think it's fair to say but actually I
enjoyed them but I did find myself
wandering off
sort of like oh I was gonna make a cup
of tea and I didn't bother pausing it I
just went in with a cup of tea knowing
but time I got back nothing would have
happened
um Lenny Henry turned up that's about it
but the last episode the fourth episode
oh my Christ
did a lot happen I had to re not only
could I not wander off to have a cup of
tea a couple of times I had to rewind it
to watch the bit again to make sure I
understood what they were saying because
it's very clear that you know
it was going to be very very important
for the whole series you know that that
all stuff and I had to rewind that price
um what do you what did you guys think
of it just generally what pulled you out
the episode didn't obviously Matt you'll
have to just tell us what you thought of
the first episode
come on guys what did you think Harris
come on
well
Okay so
can I start with the question can I
start with the questions okay just to
get out of the way I think Lord of the
Rings rings of power has it's it's it's
definitely getting to it where it's
pretty damn good but I I wouldn't say
it's woke in any way and that's that's
all I will say about that it's proven
it's telling a narrative it's telling a
story and it's not trying to push
anything which is good but
if it wasn't Lord of the Rings
would you have kept watching this show
after the first three episodes with
their pacing and how slow it was and not
really happening yes yes
there I I don't know if I could actually
answer that you know just because it is
Lord of the Rings and that's kept me in
episode four and five have been
phenomenal episode five almost makes me
say yeah like Rings the power dragon
from where we are just because I know
since battle's here but battles
Dragon so
they're almost equal to me at this point
but I don't know if I would like the
first three of the five episodes we've
gotten with ring of power as much as it
wasn't Lord of the Rings
well I'm not a fan of I said I said it
earlier I'm not a massive fan of Lord of
the Rings that made me happy I went into
it
just because it looked it looks like the
kind of TV show I would watch
and I'm enjoying it so if it wasn't Lord
of the Rings if it didn't have Lord of
the Rings plastered on the title and I
didn't know it was Lord of the Rings I
would still like it good oh yeah sorry
okay it's doing his job then I'm with
you I'm not sure
but because of the production value
that's that's where the question
we know they spent a billion dollars
that's that's how you spend your 350 400
million dollars on your first three
episodes
I just don't know if that I like it I
don't love it I like it but I don't know
if that's a proper way of spending that
type of type of money you know uh for
the type of IP and everything that it is
that's true you know uh but if it wasn't
Lord of the Rings he had been a quarter
billion dollars cheaper also true very
true factors everywhere
and we could have gotten a decent Tom
Swift
with a good dad and son story but okay
fine
they'd have been looking at 600 million
instead of a billion wouldn't they which
is uh it's still ridiculous but gotta
remember this this billion dollars they
keep throwing around if that is that
money is going to be trickling through
almost the entire series a lot of that
investment they've they've done they've
spent a lot of money in the beginning so
I think this you know
250 million dollars a season is still a
lot of 200 million dollars a season it's
still quite a lot of money but
it's not as ridiculous as what some
people have been suggesting that way
um the new um Last Airbender series that
Netflix are doing they're spending 15 16
million dollars an episode oh yeah on
The Last Airbender
another cartoon that was brilliant that
is a bombed at least twice so
Netflix better know what they're doing
on that one
so um
what what did you think stormy it's like
if you if you watched once you get to
the fourth episode
that makes me then look back at the
first three episodes and there go
actually that yeah it was a bit boring
all of a sudden it's
it's almost like it proves that like
yeah I was writing but it's but it's oh
this is getting better sort of thing
would you agree with that
I'd definitely you know um in the later
episodes things picked up and
I think what's coming well there there
was excuse me there was so much to cover
I mean you know you have the the whole
story I mean there's God how many lines
of stories going on
you know I mean you have the hard foot
you have the stranger you know uh you
you've got the the the plight of
Hysteria you've got all these things and
it's converging on something and so I'm
get it's like in the first of any kind
of series it takes time to get you
informed on what all the characters are
and I think this story is so complex I
mean if anyone's just read the
silmarillion you understand this is much
more complex than something like The
Hobbit or a Fellowship of the Ring
really really complex story and so
but yeah I mean the payoff the the two
or three episodes in the beginning the
payoff in late in the episode four or
five is tremendous I think yeah I think
that's that's fine there's an awful lot
in this series to set up and to get and
to get going a lot of somebody said to
me because um because no Lord of the
Rings is the setup I'm like no this is 6
000 years before it
like I said before there's a lot of
material to cover
yeah
do you just have those up with you all
the time
yes I do carries them to work just in
case someone brings up Lord of the Rings
you can pull them out and slide them
over and just say you're wrong
but if anybody tries to rob you you've
got a massive status yeah
right you need to be armed to just throw
my gun like projectiles right yeah yeah
oh really you think you bring it in my
house well here's more goth ring jackass
yeah you've heard of chanclas and here
comes Stormy with some Lord of the Rings
books
but I tell you about that I I'm actually
getting a little bit excited I think the
main thing is after the first three
episodes I wasn't like excited for the
next episode I wasn't like oh what's
gonna happen now after this last episode
I'm like I do I can I am actually
looking forward to it is it Thursday I'm
looking forward to the episode coming
out because I really want to see you've
seen the fifth episode right it's this
episode isn't it um
the guy that looks like young Eminem
that's I thought that okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay so that's a whole new
segue to come in there you know I was
going to ask you guys who the m m guy
was actually because again am I supposed
to know who that is who who I think
they're trying to make us ask is he
Sauron who who Sauron uh but who who is
halbrand Sauron is
hey Adar I don't think you're Sauron I
don't think who knows I don't there's my
brain can go every different way you
know I thought it was an elf at first
and then but in the snow is it that that
is broken the things I thought it was an
elf
yeah a lot of really hardcore fans they
they're well they're thinking well he
could be one of three people
you know and a lot of excuse me
a lot of the uh characters in this are
are
in in the books they have kind of a
minor role that set up other parts of
the story and we're wondering if it's
one of those but it's definitely
um
some people think he's Sauron some
people not it's
uh in it and they think that whoever
that guy is that person is
uh it greatly depends who they are
greatly depends on who the stranger is
is it is the stranger one of the blue
Wizards or is it it seems like it's
Gandalf I that it just it seems like
they're setting up Gandalf with him a
little bit
the blue wizard you mean there or
whatever that wizard is yeah the
stranger yeah yeah we can't call the
wizard I'm not like to go in the
Wizard's way but I don't know I did I
love the Wolves scene I did like the
wolf scene when the when the little
things over there hiding in the tree and
he just goes
oh that's pretty cool I saw an odd
theory about it someone said those three
wolves worked a little too in Tandem and
stormy you might know more about it
because I don't know where werewolves
are involved with in Middle Earth at all
but apparently those three
elves The Slim Shady the m m looking kid
um they might be werewolves I guess I
don't know I don't know if that turns
into Tom Bombadil kind of territory or
what but or yeah um
um
there's lots of there's lots of a token
would have called fell creatures you
know uh in around Middle Earth you know
orgs were one of them because the Orcs
rode them there's all sorts of things
you know
um
uh Tolkien would just write uh poetry
about things that would kind of fit in
Middle Earth one was the muellips of the
form about the new lips and how
treacherous and they were in the dark
and so I mean it could have been you
know the these uh wolves I don't think
werewolves but they were shape Changers
okay Warren was a shape changer he went
Yeah from Big Guy to angry flying bear
which was the best thing ever
you know
all right okay well that works
um that's the thing is that there's so
many there's so much material for them
to explore in this they're going to keep
us guessing and um and and so they
should so yeah we'll see oh my God you
know keeping this guessing that's a
really good point because if you ever
read some of the hardcore you know
Discord servers I mean that's a well oh
my god well you know in this book it
mentions something on page 87 in
paragraph three could that be alluding
to some other and they go on for you
know until the next week I mean it's
just wow
I don't think I'm an expert in anything
to the degree
yourself don't mean other people are
experts in Tolkien oh well I consider
myself a trekking and I do not go into
the detail you guys do
um there's a lot of these other guys
that are really hard I am nowhere near
that
I'm not in the one percent geek hood
that these I mean they are
oh my God they have no other life they
they don't have a life at all outside of
token just put all these
all those bloody books tend to suggest
you might have no life
um
I I love it but I don't love it to that
degree I gotta say but hey I'm excited
about the next episode though that's the
bonus then yeah you screwed all your
camera with The Hobbit well then it
looks like a killed kids version
I I found it I didn't I didn't buy it
it was a door stop right
I was in I was working in like a
shopping center and it was in a plant
pot and I was like
okay I thought you're gonna say I was in
a shopping center and this isn't a
Waterstone so I just sort of took it
now mate that's theft
that's shoplifting but
I just saw this level
nobody was wearing it so I just took it
just took it yeah just took it in uh so
what else if anybody watched this week
before we call it an evening
um I've guessed anybody in the comments
you've seen anything you've got
particularly excited about or is there
anything
I know you've seen the first episode I
haven't I have not seen the episode
actually what have you guys seen The
quantum leave yet is it any good have
not seen it I've not seen it yet so
maybe next week we'll have a bit of a
conversation about that yeah I'm worried
about it
it's all right
why didn't they uh I've never seen the
original series but why didn't they get
is it Scott Bakula what's his name Scott
Bakula yeah but Sam Sam Becca yeah
why did he never get back
um it's they basically suggested that
actually he was like on on a mission
from God
so he did have an opportunity to escape
but it would have meant somebody else
somebody who's trying to help would have
suffered so he
just kept going
so yeah they suggested I'm not actually
I don't think they suggested I think he
actually met somebody that basically
said
this is meant to be your
you know you're meant to be here so uh
Rodrigo we talked about and or at the
start of the video mates just rewind it
when you when we talked about it right
um
there have been issues with Quantum leak
but um oh I think um Kevin just said
actually Scott bakulan to dispute
um there was issues towards the end of
the original series of quantum League
they were going to have another series
but Scott pecula wasn't happy about his
deal and things but in this series they
tried they did want to bring him back
and for it to be a continuation and
apparently Scott Bakula refused he
didn't want to come back so they've had
to do a hard reboot because Scott bakul
refused to do to appear
um and nobody quite knows why there's
loads of contradictory stores online so
it's a bit it's a bit of a loved one
because this it would have been so easy
just to do a continuation
and it would have been really easy
um it is a continuation oh is it set up
I was going to ask you actually is it
set up continuation it is set up like a
continuation because they they'd speak
about Beckett yeah go getting trapped
and and how he never made it home
and the first episode is essentially
um
so I don't I never watched The Originals
did they have like an AI super computer
in the in the originals yes
Ziggy yeah yeah so yeah in in the first
episode The New Guy Ben who is
essentially the new Sam Beckett
um
for some reason jumped into the quantum
leaper
without any explanation
like no one knows why he changed the
algorithm he jumped in and now we're
we're just following the journey
okay so we'll find out why he's done it
at some point but everything that
happened before has happened so it's a
continuation it is a continuation
because one of the rumors was they were
going to do that it would be his
daughter because he had a child while he
was in the leap
um so it was Sam but he was in someone
else's body if you know what I mean he
had a child and that daughter then now
worked at Quantum Leap she worked
together there is a there was a mention
of a woman who was someone's daughter
right so we think that's Sam's daughter
but also I don't know if it's time I
don't think they said Sam
but I think the guy who's died who died
Dean something
I was the actor yeah he died well yes I
think I think
the the character was he in the original
series
yeah or was he like yeah okay
the project Observer was that his time
at project
he would advise Sam and stuff
the what the hologram door so when when
I can't remember doing stockhol's
character's name in the series that's
that's horrible I can't remember it but
anyway he would come through and the
door would open and he'd sort of like
stumble through like he was doing
something else like he's like oh hello
and he'd have that little uh control
panel thing
um
on the side of the quantum leaper they
kind of just appear
[Music]
well I'll look forward to that when it
comes over here in the UK so anytime in
the next six months we should get that
because y'all are gonna kill me but the
most familiar I am with Quantum Leap
is the episode of It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia
where Scott Bakula Bakula or whatever
his name is popped up is the janitor in
that one little place and starts singing
that song oh
have you seen that episode where the the
gang gets turned into yeah
I wonder if Quantum Leap was the last of
the really great TV shows that had
um just brilliant opening sequences just
like that the musical
um there's a thing going around Facebook
it says my mom says photos can't speak
or can't make noise and then it's a
picture of Airwolf and everybody of my
generation immediately goes
in our brains
um because that was just iconic a team
Knight Rider
um all these shows just have iconic
music and I just don't think shows do
anymore
Game of Thrones is really the only one
in recent memory that has like that
I iconic kind of thing to like really
remember
yeah it's just dramatic starting but I
couldn't I couldn't sing it here but
around all the Airwolf ones
go and watch the open sequence to
werewolf terrible TV show if I don't
ever watch
you stormy you'll know these two Whipper
Snappers have no clue but um I'd go
whack and watch I can watch Knight Rider
that's not too bad I can watch The
A-Team and that's no okay but oh God
it's a bit cheesy I I can't watch
um
Airwolf it's so Camp it's unbelievable
it's just unwatchable they could have
done so they could have done such
amazing things with that idea and they
chose not to
I mean we just literally
bad yeah it was not a good show I loved
it when I was a kid but I mean I watched
it back okay I wonder if it really was
as good as I remember no no it wasn't it
was Bloody awful but Knight Riders some
of the episodes of Knight Rider still go
um but yeah it's just like don't go back
and don't go back and watch the original
1980s Thundercats that's also terrible
He-Man from back then terrible I loved
it when I was a kid anyway
sorry but is it better than the new
stuff at least because people don't like
the new stuff you know
um actually I think the new stuff might
be a little bit but the news the new
thingy man was very much done in the
style of the original He-Man so that's
why it's actually a bit [ __ ] and because
it's done like a 1980s cartoon and it's
very much the same style so if you watch
that and then watch the 1980s cartoon
you can go Ah that's why you did it okay
there's been been a little bit too
clever for his own good therein if you
tried to do something that was that felt
like the original and it did come across
a bit of [ __ ]
and but at least He-Man was in a couple
of episodes towards the end which is
good
well that's good yeah uh my screw just
changed that's weird right anyway guys
so let's call it a day I'm gonna go have
my dinner it's in the oven Yum Yum Yum
Yum Yum go have dinner yeah and I'm
horribly hung over so I'm just at that
stage when I really need to eat
so um I gotta I got a quick question for
you every [ __ ] week I mean
so I just finished my
all-encompassing Stargate binge watching
I'm done with that what should I start
on
what's the next thing that I should
start on that I don't know about just
watch dark anger what are you feeling
I don't know I don't know
I mean do I start on X-Files
it's it's brilliant yeah this is great
um you get to around season six or seven
it goes off the rails for a couple of
Seasons but they just come back relax on
Disney plus yeah
um I was thinking
or if you're not something about Brad
right Travelers is good
I disagree with you oh my God
traffic is amazing no I thought I really
wanted to like it but I didn't
watch it again you didn't watch it right
TV over there and I was over here damn
it
I was just like I've got a drinking
problem
I've got a TV watching problem yeah
um I I only got about four or five
episodes in did I need to stick did I
need to stick to it tonight yeah it's
what it's like I I loved it from the
from the off but it gets way better as
it goes on okay I'll give it another try
some point maybe I'll tell you what I'm
watching at the moment I'm really
watching Babylon five
well before he makes a new series and
probably ruins it I thought I would get
a lot of comments right so I would love
to know what you guys think about this
get a lot of comments going well they're
going to do this new version of Babylon
five it will ruin the original
wow
how can it ruin the original like the
good light of that with Stargate as well
well they'll make new Stargate but it'll
be terrible and it'll be woken it'll be
rubbish and it'll ruin Stargate for me
why
the original's still there yeah
if they make a new series it's it's no
good just go back and watch the original
you know when I was re-watching Stargate
Universe
I really want wanted I could have done
another season if somebody would have
just gotten around to shooting Telford
in the face
I mean I thoroughly disliked that
character I just really did
the the problem with
Universe was the characters for me Eli
was the only likable character in the
whole damn you know I you know it's um
I I actually like to I mean
Rush certainly has its issues but I
liked him as a character you know it was
like yeah and he had such distrust of
everybody else it made him look
Squirrely and many times he was because
uh the the colonel oh God
uh Telford Colonel Telford not Telfer
the other one the one that was a drunk
Unleashed that was drinks
yeah yeah thank you he was a terrible
leader how did he I mean terrible leader
he was awful and I it was just and it
and
I'm wondering well is that one reason
why Rush was so secretive throughout
everything is because he didn't I mean
he already hit Rush already has trust
issues
and was that the reason why
because he knew who uh young was and
that was one reason why he kept a lot of
things to himself because young was to
commanded all the guns yeah
and evidently there was a big Schism on
the ship because they had an uprising a
civilian Uprising against the military I
think Russia could definitely see uh
young was going through some sort of
internal conflict yeah and that probably
did
add to his
um let's make the civilians in charge
I did a video on it a couple of days ago
and I was just well if we went back and
saved Eli but it might actually look
this is how I would do it it's just my
idea but basically I killed everybody
and I just said all the pods broke down
and we would see little flashbacks of
Eli trying to save them but he just
couldn't the Destiny was dead just
floating and between the two galaxies it
never made it
um and we just about saved it I said it
was too dark and I was like no I thought
I said but from my point of view I was
doing it the universe's theme very well
yeah I thought so it was very dark show
anyway but also I thought are we going
to be able to get those actors back
because I can know two or three have
gone on to other big projects and
there's no chance they're coming back
um you could probably get
um young back because I think he's done
a few big things but I don't think he's
in anything major at the moment but
other than that I've only seen him in
like one episode of Breaking Bad when I
was at
well there goes yeah uh he did swap for
a couple years and he did something else
as well it was in it was in Travelers
yeah
frigidly seized in three uh universe is
in comic book form because it left
everything hanging and it didn't get
picked up again for a third season
there's a like a five issue I think it's
five issues or something of what
happened to Eli and all of that and I'm
dying I you know I've read synopsis and
it really don't make that much sense I
don't think I've got an Electronics
um a load of Builders wake up basically
so there's there's pods on
the
um ship I've read this in years so I'm
gonna have to help me out a little bit
but basically there's pods from natural
the Builders of the destiny and they
wake up
and um and then so Eli's already sorted
the power issue doesn't he so they've
got enough power so they can get to the
he has yeah he sorted out some sort of
power
curtain wasn't he that surrounded yeah
but that inadvertently opens up more
pods that they hadn't discovered and
that's where the engineers come in the
original Builders of Destiny yeah the
reason that they're on the ship
um is because Destiny left when they
were on it they weren't meant to be
there but they just went into the stasis
um they they get they they wake up they
basically like
uh they're not happy they're trying to
take the ship yeah we're there to try
and take the ship back
um
and it's it's only two there's only two
issues it literally yeah at the end of
the first issue we find out that the the
these these people on on board
and then they have a conversation they
pretty much like whack what's his name
Scott Matthew Scott and the back of the
head have a little conversation and then
that's it you never hear anything from
it but the one thing that we do get from
it
that I really love is the communication
Stones they there's a little throwaway
comment they make and it's oh we use
those as children's toys
[Laughter]
beyond that nothing else ever happens
like we never find out anything yeah it
was too I always thought it was just
supposed to be the opening two episodes
covered really it was a it wasn't the
whole series but Joseph malozi said that
they had did they did have the whole
series mapped out they knew where they
were going with it and then apparently
they only found out they were getting
canceled
um as they're about to film the last two
or three episodes
so that's why the um so that's the way
we never really got a an end because
they just didn't have time to do
something so they just reworked that
last bit to so it felt like a conclusion
or something but I think they hoped they
might get a TV movie out of it and they
were still talking about that apparently
but obviously never happened
guys what happens in Stargate
yes
but in about five years when you get
Stargate Universe you'll look back on
this video and know exactly what we were
talking about hey I'm on a good page now
it might only take three
what so what you need is a heart case of
covert and then you can do it all you
know that's what I've proven you get a
hot case of coven you can do it all
right come close to the camera
it's techno born at this point at this
point
something got it and then I got it and
then Matt's got it Matt's got it
your house
you're next
we need to get together because you're
just on the other side of the mountains
for me yeah
I don't know go to jail together or
something you know it's always a good
time I've never been out to California
but we might as well try there's a first
time for everything or or you know you
could uh come up here visit me and I can
take you show you some of the uh crazy
uh secret uh petroglyphs
oh he's doing lots of videos about
petroglyphs secret petroglyphs
and then I just tell me a time and a day
and I'll I'll come that way yeah yeah
deal yeah right now I'm always good just
let me know
so and then me and Matt were talking
about this the other day because
actually he only lives about really 20
miles from me so we're gonna do a we'll
have a meet-up video at some point
shortly we we should me and you meet up
you install me meet up and we'll do a
live and it'll be two cameras yeah but
there'll be four of us on it and then we
just change it and then we change
cameras
why not if you'd like however you want
to do I don't care but anyway okay I
gotta go eat starving hungry and this is
a lovely as always guys thank you so
much
um Kevin McCabe I know you've struggled
to find the Battlestar Galactica episode
I'm just going to videos and scroll down
and it's a the pictures of two cylons so
you'll you'll find it
um
he loves those books morgoth's ring
sounds dirty
it sounds like
grown up Lord of the Rings but hey next
week we will have a proper topic we will
think of something it's not because I
was lazy and couldn't be bothered so we
just did it
because you couldn't be rather than
you're lazy we all know that was the
reason a little bit so um next week
we'll think of something to talk about
probably so guys thank you so so much
Matt thank you as always for joining
the young whipper snapper who can't get
covered apparently as always yeah
um my side track hoodie is on order I
can't believe I've I and I haven't got
one but it's starting to get cold now so
mine's on this way and again thank you
very much I really do appreciate this
you are very welcome and what else now
did you get your mug as well I can't
remember name no this was just it now I
got you two things
hmm
I'm gonna have to go back onto the
website and check that I actually
ordered two things
well you didn't pay for the postage for
one so I mean you know who knows I think
it could still be rattling around a post
office someplace it might do so right
okay
right I'll have a look but anyway guys
have a lovely one have a great week stay
safe Harris stay away from anybody with
a cough yes
I'm gonna be in the movie theater I've
been spending too much time there I'll
run away from him there
it's gonna have to be in a room with
people coughing on each other with bad
air conditioners
yeah it is working so far yeah guys
thank you so so much
y'all be good thanks for watching
bye bye
[Music]